the budget is what he does and the two
are from different planets I like to say
the budget is the truth serum and now
the American people can clearly see that
he is a fraud who is not fighting for
them under Donald Trump the average
American is struggling to keep up and
his budget would make life harder for
them
president Trump likes to talk about the
Forgotten man and woman well in this
budget he's forgotten about the very
people he promised to help in his State
of the Union last week so let me go over
a few of the areas on health care the
president said he'd never cut Medicare
and Medicaid he slashes both 1 trillion
in cuts to Medicaid in the Affordable
Care Act hundreds of billions of cuts in
Medicare and the president even proposes
a 35 million dollar cut to CDC's
infectious disease Rapid Response
reserve fund this is the fund currently
currently being used to respond to the
corona virus outbreak on education the
President's budget would devastate our
nation's students both K through 12 and
college his budget cuts the cuts the
strengthening institutions program that
assists historically black colleges and
universities and other minority serving
institutions typical hypocrisy at the
State of the Union he was bragging how
he helps HBCUs his budget cuts them cuts
them it cuts after school and summer
learning programs for 2 million young
people rural education grants will hurt
18,000 school districts across the
country if the president in the
President's budget hundreds of billions
of dollars would be slashed from student
loan forgiveness he actually makes it
harder for kids to pay back their debt
instead of a limit of 10 percent of
income per year
it goes up to 12 and a half under his
budget that's how he cares about
students and the overwhelming burden of
debt they have he slashes federal
housing assistance
he slashes federal disability insurance
so if you're an American struggling with
student loan debt or health problems or
housing costs or hunger the President's
budget says you're out of luck meanwhile
if you're a millionaire billionaire a
corporation a big oil wildcatter the
President's budget says you're in luck
you're in clover and lastly the
President's budget doesn't make it
harder to fight climate change alone it
would exacerbate make worse the crime
climate crisis not just not fight it but
make it worse
he cuts EPA funding by more than 25%
he cuts renewable energy funding clean
energy like wind and solar 75% and cuts
funding for climate research Gashouse
green monitoring and emissions reduction
activities in this anti-science
administration that he leads president's
budget president Trump's budget even
cuts disaster relief for FEMA by twelve
point two billion dollars and so much of
the disaster is caused by climate the
Earth's on fire Antarctica had a 64
degree record temperature this week and
what is the president's response he
douses the fire with lighter fluid of
weaken pollution regulations and then
proposes cutting the fire department we
know how much he cares about the oil
companies but his budget makes clear he
doesn't give a hoot about the future of
this globe and is fine leaving to our
children and grandchildren a globe in
much worse shape even than it is today
speaker Pelosi thank you very much
leader humor for your leadership and
fighting this budget the budget our
federal budget should be a statement of
our national values what it's important
to us as a nation should be reflected in
how we allocate our resources the budget
in terms of our legislative work is the
heart of the matter it's where it all
begins and this is a heartless budget
it's a heartless budget in some of the
ways that
it's English leader spelled out and I
think it does bear a petition to say
what he is doing
slashing a half a trillion dollars for
Medicare after he stood in front of the
houses that I'm protecting Medicare so a
half a trillion dollars out of Medicare
and from Medicaid nine hundred billion
dollars so if you're sitting at home at
your kitchen table and you're a senior
or you there's a senior in your family
on Medicare you're getting cut and if
there is long-term care and in your
family's budget you are getting cut two
thirds of long-term care two-thirds of
long-term care is paid for by Medicaid
this is a middle-class benefit those
cuts endanger the health of seniors and
long-term care needs and for them and
their families and these Medicaid cuts
also hurt rural hospitals people seeking
opioid addiction treatment veterans and
their families more than a million
veterans are on Medicaid so nine hundred
billion dollars cut from Medicaid at the
same time the president is a court
fighting to overturn the Affordable Care
Act which has as you mentioned the
pre-existing condition benefit so
important to all of those families but
in this budget what could possibly be
his motivation to cut all that money
from the cgc that you mentioned at the
time of the Colonna virus and the threat
that that is cutting members money from
CDs the Center for Disease Control using
the full title the prevention element of
the good health of the American people
what could pop what could he be thinking
maybe I'm using that term loosely the
president said he would fight for
farmers we all want to fight performers
but at a time when farmers are declaring
bankruptcy at record rates the president
in this budget wants to slash the safety
net by nearly 60 billion dollars and
ransack the US Department of Agriculture
his budget also takes food off the table
of hungry families of both rural and
urban
communities by cutting more than 180
billion dollars from the SNAP program
SNAP program some farmers when I visit
farmers in the Midwest they say we are
farmers and we are on food stamps it's
such a sad thing their economies depends
that's when Senator Dole and Senator
McGovern even began all of this was to
help people meet their have food
security but also to help farmers have
their Economic Security as well
countless groups representing seniors
and working families and more have
denounced the budget from the AL
Alliance for Retired Americans to the
young Invincibles young young
invincibles a young lobbyist you've
probably seen them we've had 10,000
events to fight the repeal of the
Affordable Care Act at which the young
they weren't at all of them but they
were significant at those meetings the
young little lobbyists some of them born
with a pre-existing condition many of
them on Medicaid they write we are
disappointed though sadly not surprised
that the president has once again broken
his campaign promise he we absolutely
reject this vision for our country and
we call upon our legislators to reject
this budget and the dangerous values it
espouses our children's lives depend on
it and the National Committee to
preserve Social Security and Medicare
rights this budget will leave seniors
and other vulnerable seniors citizens
hungrier sicker and poorer
it reveals the president's cruel
priorities heading into the 2020
election chairman mentioned earlier that
their benefits to the high end in our
economic life in our country the
president in his what he has been doing
what he talked about in the State of the
Union and what this budget is about
increases the national debt passes that
expense
on to our children so that he can give
tax cuts to the top one percent in our
country it's absolutely shameful against
that budget supposed to be a statement
of our values once again this president
is demin
straining how little he values the good
health financial security and well-being
a hard-working American families this
budget is an insult to the hopes and
dreams and aspirations of America's
working families it increases the
national debt it must be rejected and by
the way it isn't a complete abandonment
of the budget agreement that we had with
a domestic and defense priorities
clearly this administration cannot be
trusted
we're ready for your questions on this
subject first yes well look we have
fought him on the wall successfully in
the budget then he tries to go around
and declare an emergency everyone knows
that that is not what the emergency
legislation was called for we're gonna
fight every penny for wall construction
we don't want to take it away from
military families what's interesting in
this budget all the military families in
all the military support that they took
out last year they didn't try to
backfill this year we didn't let them in
last year's budget so who is this gonna
hurt our nation's military our nation's
military families for a wall that is a
vanity project that he said Mexico would
pay for further to that point the
distinguished leader has been very clear
but this is about child care centers at
military bases facilities for the
quality of life for the families and for
the security of our country as he said
Mexico is going to pay for it no but in
addition to the harm that he's doing to
military families just getting back to
medicaid's
almost a trillion dollars in cuts in
Medicaid it over million veterans are on
Medicaid hundreds of millions of
veterans are on food stamps so this
really is shows just a cavalier attitude
to the needs
America's servicemen and women and their
families when they're in the military
and when they're retired the gang of six
to the needs of America's servicemen and
women and their families when they're in
the military and when they retired the
gang of six Medicare was happy portable
Care Act is how we strengthened Medicare
so don't buy into that false premise
ocean not and Medicare in fact we
increased the longevity of it and that
has been one of the things they say all
you use Medicare but we did not we did
not he didn't he didn't put it way way
way he didn't put a nickel of that back
into health care not a nickel that's the
difference or to Medicare yeah so he's
not you he may use that argument but he
will use it falsely this is very
important that we have clarity on this
subject because we're talking about
America's working families we're talking
about Medicare which is essential to the
not only the health but the financial
security we are also talking about
Medicaid which is a middle-income
benefit although people think of it
being for poor people poor children yes
but as I mentioned over to about
two-thirds of it being of long-term care
being covered by Medicaid which is now
being cut by almost a trillion 900 900
billion dollars but also to put this in
a perspective about what that means to
America's working families why are they
doing this they're doing this so that
they can give advantages to the high end
we want to see balance in all this we
want to see where we can find savings
let's subject everything we spend
to harsh scrutiny so that the results
for the American people are the best
that they can be but don't get in front
of an audience and say I'm here to
protect Medicare Social Security and
people and we say Medicaid too and then
put a budget like this fort and then try
to say we did something on the health
care bill which we did not try a check
this subject I don't blame them would
you want that subjected to exposure
speaker Pelosi says it well you want to
know the values of a president don't
listen in with this president in
particular to the State of the Union
address look at his budget and it shows
his values are so off-base left to his
own devices he would do this we stop him
we fight him but make no mistake about
it this is just what he wants to do and
the American people shouldn't know about
it loud and clear we have a saying in
the house show me your budget show me
your values that's where it is and this
is really a statement so undermining of
the values of America is as a community
what we are about respecting what the
needs are of America's working families
this is really important because it is
also part of the anti governance
attitude of the Republican suit what
they can diminish Medicaid diminished
Social Security take away the disability
benefits reduce the disability benefits
in Social Security what's the what is
the advantage of that and that might add
because the distinguished leader talked
about education there's nothing that
brings more money to the Treasury than
investment in education early childhood
K through 12
education post post-grad and lifetime
learning for a worker so when they say
they're making a cut in education
they're making they're increasing the
national debt and undermining the
aspirations of the American people and
the competitiveness of our country this
subject you are you did you are you to
this subject nope the subject first come
on the non-defense side not the
defensive well we're going to write our
bills according to the agreement that we
have with the administration and as we
did this year we were able to avoid a
shutdown even though the president was
threatening one because we honored the
budget agreement in a bipartisan way
House and Senate and that's what we will
do again one more on this subject and
then we'll stray a bit yes we'll get you
the details there are cuts in programs
that benefit Medicare that go to
Medicare absolutely yes look both of us
stand strongly and our whole caucuses do
from one end to the other that we want
to do everything we can to get rid of
citizens united that we want to go back
to the days of real campaign finance
reform and we stand for that plain and
simple and we will if we get the
majority if God willing the speaker
keeps the majority I think both or have
a good chance of happening that's going
to be a top priority for us now we
passed HR 1 and HR 1 we did three things
when we ran in 2018 for the people we
said we were going to lower the cost of
health care for America's families by
lowering the cost of prescription drugs
as we protected the pre-existing
condition benefit lower health care
bigger paychecks by building the
infrastructure of America in a green way
a resilient way for the future we
thought in those two areas we could find
some common ground with the
administration because the president
said he was going to negotiate like
crazy on reducing costs of a
prescription drug I guess like crazy
means not at all and hopefully we can
still find a pass on both of those lower
costs of prescription drugs and building
the infrastructure and three cleaner
government I don't know that we had much
hope with him in that regard however it
was about and lowering the influence of
dark special interest money in elections
as well as a giving opportunity for
small donors to weigh in but everybody
thought that his or her voice counted as
much as anyone elses
was John Lewis's provisions in there to
end voter suppression and the rest of
that we have three bills you have three
bills on the floor right now in terms of
election security and that is the shield
Act the Safet Act elements of HR 1 why
are the repeal
it's so afraid of stopping foreign
interference in our elections why are
the Republicans so afraid of protecting
the integrity of our elections and
protecting the we did get money over
four hundred million dollars in the it's
not an omnibus minibus were ever that we
passed at the end of last year hurdle
string over his objections because he is
standing in the way of the election
integrity that we need as far as Michael
Bloomberg is concerned I think that his
his involvement in this campaign will be
a positive one and by the way just one
other point on that HR one we have asked
countless times from McConnell to let us
bring it to the floor to bring it to the
floor he won't do it he's against any
campaign finance reform Bloomberg is
concerned I think that his his
involvement in this campaign will be a
positive one and by the way just one
other point of that HR one we have asked
countless times from McConnell to let us
bring it to the floor to bring it to the
floor he won't do it he's against any
campaign finance reform seriously in my
view the the Voting Rights Act but said
Congress can't correct this and we did
and he won't bring that up to and across
the country those who are interested in
the Voting Rights Act are paying keen
attention to the fact that he will not
even bring up a Voting Rights Act which
we passed when we passed originally in
of 607 president I mean was oh six but
can't be affected but oh seven President
Bush signed it it was overwhelming I
think unanimous in the Senate in the
house four hundred votes something like
that and now we can't even get it
brought up on the same both bills are
part of McConnell's legislative
graveyard last question
you primaries are primaries and there
are always lots of Sturm and Drang
you will see in a few months Democrats
will be strongly United together and we
will be focused like a laser on beating
Donald Trump the enthusiasm that you
last saw in 2008 to elect Barack Obama
you will see among Democrats this summer
and fall to get Donald Trump out of
office and we in the house that we set a
model for how to win elections by
winning in the most gerrymandered voter
suppressed political arena you could
ever put together net gain of 40 seats
so we think we are an engine that can
help us win that election whoever our
nominee is thank you
[Music]
respect
so Katniss phenom saga that is all the
CC withou
[Music]
the FDA state gig Alice was ins at CityU
our smart leader and near whom and the
IFD vested Celia